are our big challenge right now is
waking up the Normie right and this is
going to be the challenge of what I'm
about to say because it's not going to
apply to anybody who watches Tim cast
any night I'm talking about my neighbors
all my neighbors 92 93 Republican
neighborhood we get together every
weekend it's it's we're all having a
blast we drink beer Luke we play no play
horseshoes we have crawfish boils the
kids play in the art it's it's it's a
blast they agree with me on all my
values they agree with everyone in this
room in general obviously we're all
different in our basic values but
they're putting their kids in college
oh man I'm so proud little Aiden got
into Stanford I'm so excited where'd
Jaden go oh Jaden got into Harvard
that's exciting the the people who share
our values are so out of touch with how
evil the traditional institutions are in
this nation the the institutions that
they previously have attended and that
they will not only still patronizing
since these institutions they'll write
them big checks they'll send their kids
there and then they'll come to
Neighborhood parties and brag about it
and I'll just sit there with my jaw
hanging open because I know the love and
care that parent took with that kid I
know that kid 18 years of love and care
and values and manners and you're so
proud but you're so unplugged you're so
not wired in that you send them off to
the wolves and like clockwork two years
later Jesse I can't believe it Aiden
came home he's got 20 rings in his face
and a Joe Biden sticker on his car and
he hates my guts and what do you want me
to tell you the Normie right the leave
me alone right but I just want to go to
work I just want to play for I just want
to watch football it's not just an army
right do you know how many people we've
had on this show who talk about the
exact same thing I've we've had
conservative guests come on the show who
complain about the left say yeah my kid
just got into college so I'm really
excited for that and I'm like do you
listen to your own videos
but I know I go through the same thing I
go to the same thing with people I know
with people I love the the right has
such a difficult time
accepting where we are and I understand
that because that's human nature I don't
even just want to indict the right it is
human nature to deny the reality of your
situation for as long as you possibly
can because it's that bad or you don't
want to bother with it that's this is
why I laugh and mock people on the right
when they say things like well we're the
silent majority what does that matter
majority means nothing they grab the
seats of power they they find the choke
holds of power that's why the Wright
will sit there and scream all day long
when there's some child drag show in
their blood red town in in Oklahoma
somewhere you know why because you were
busy being the silent majority and the
Communists were busy taking over your
Public Library taking over your city
government while you were flipping
burgers and playing fantasy football he
was grabbing the seats of power and when
you explain these things to them they're
shocked I remember just like it was
yesterday one night just one last point
on this one night I'm sitting around the
table is 10 couples there and we're all
and I don't talk a lot of politics they
all know what I do but I don't like to
do that that at a party so I just kind
of chill and relax but it came up
someone asked me it's about something
and I brought up ESG
now we're talking with successful people
here all of them wired in our values
successful people here not one man or
woman at that table had ever even heard
ESG and when I explained what ESG was
and told them all I said everyone right
now pick up your cell phone and look up
your bank I guarantee your bank has a
dedicated ESG page on it they all
thought I was a nut job conspiracy
theorist you could have heard a pin drop
in there over the next five minutes as
they discovered the reality of the world
they live in until the Normie right that
shares normal values realizes it's in a
war a culture war and there will be one
Victor then 20 years maybe a hundred
they've got a lot of waking up to do and
it's going to take years they're
rebranding ESG by the way according to
James Lindsay it's you're going to stop
hearing it they'll be like oh yes G was
crazy now it's called like Global
something I'll bring that up tomorrow to
clarify you know you talked about people
denying reality until the very last
second when it's painful I think that
with voting I don't think voting matters
anymore
yeah well here's it may or may not now
this is what I want to explain obviously
they cheat in elections and when I say
that don't tell me they don't there's a
reason the entire Democratic party
thinks voter ID is illegal that's it
should be illegal that's insane you
should obviously have to show an ID the
only reason you wouldn't want that is
because you cheat and want to cheat some
more so don't tell me they don't cheat
but setting that aside the right again
back to the Normie right even people who
are activists activists of some way you
know what our participation is in
primaries 20 Democrats participate 50 in
primary Wisconsin yeah yeah exactly
Republicans 20 so we wonder why the
Democratic party's gone full-blown
Communists in the past 10 years and yet
we still have a bunch of Limp wrist and
losers running the Low T GOP in this
country that's because the Communists
show up and vote and and what we what do
we do we throw a trump sticker on our
car and say Donald Trump will save us
and we skip the local primary or even
worse we show up and vote for the same
turd who just voted but listen listen I
agree with you on all that but I don't
think that changes anything I just said
well you said that I don't agree with
because having kids is not enough it's
important but it's not grabbing the
seats of power if you're gonna grab kids
and still sending Aiden off to Stanford
then you didn't it's not a Net game that
that I understand but that still doesn't
matter the cities are destroying
themselves this stuff doesn't work if
someone if someone came to me and said I
am deeply concerned by this new movement
of people who are you know harming
themselves I'd be like well over a long
enough period of time they won't exist
because they've harmed themselves you
could say that about the CCP having the
one child policy but they didn't destroy
themselves because they have such an
authoritarian weaponized system
but that's that's not what I'm talking
about see the thing about the CCP is
that they just kidnap and murder people
and while the United States certainly
has those capabilities as well they're
not the U.S has safeguards and
protections that I think will be
weakened be damaged are being eroded but
will probably stand through a stand
strong enough to where
I I think over the long enough period of
time a combination of factors the
foundation of this country and and the
Constitution itself with all the attacks
against it and the fact that it's big
and partially decentralized more so than
many of these other countries
as long as we keep up the culture War
battle as long as we say don't buy
Anheuser-Busch here's all you got to do
Jesse when you have those parties just
let your neighbors the couples that are
coming over say hey don't don't buy any
beer my treat I'm taking care of it then
you go and you buy the beer and you
don't buy Bush on that one I will say
this for some good news this was this
past weekend was probably the first
weekend I hung out with those same
neighbors where to a man every Tom Dick
and Harry showed up and they were all
talking about the Bud Light thing and it
was all negative this was the thing that
really snapped what I'm saying economic
management nuts yeah this was the thing
they they all brought it to me gotta get
rid of the Bud Light good grief this is
horrible won't be buying that again
that's what I'm saying when I saw the
reaction to the Bud Light story I said I
think we have an opportunity to reach
regular people with this striking at
beer was the biggest mistake they made
but they had to make it I'm imagining
there's this great Battlefield and we'll
make a metaphor of it with the with the
awoke people looking over a map and and
it's the year is 20 11 and they're like
okay our first move is to send our
troops into video games and video game
journalism because older people won't
won't see and that means the commanders
on the right will ignore it it may
bother young people but if we get a
foothold there we can then spread our
troops around and gain control of movies
and literature and and TV shows and then
the tenant says but sir what about this
area and he points to beer no no don't
go near that one we don't have near
enough power in the culture War to
strike at something as prominent as beer
and they thought now is that time and
maybe I don't think so but maybe they
said we have gained enough ground in
enough institutions to where we can now
muster us an incursion on beer
and they're hoping that the right is
weakened and more or less to the point
where their weird insane cult garbage
will actually successfully take over
beer I'm confident that they don't have
the power to do so especially if forces
like ours tell people to resist to this
degree problem I'm having you guys and
I'm severely black pilled on voting
maybe you can help me that they are
tallying votes on proprietary voting
machines in in Pub in private makes me
feel so right I I just don't want to
deviate from the cultural stuff I know
the cultural surface of the victory that
is the win but we're talking about it's
holistically like
your metaphor about raising young
conservative kids that then they will
vote and fix the system I don't feel
that the voting I didn't say anything
yes but what I'm saying is right now our
victory has to be cultural the point is
have kids
overwhelm the system to a degree where
whatever you think it doesn't matter
if if we're looking at four to one in
the votes you win hands down if no
matter what's done in secret how it
doesn't matter it just doesn't matter
that's what Stalin said it doesn't
matter who who make who votes it matters
uh I think I think my cameras are not
plugged in we better plug it yeah I
think it's about to die you need to plug
it in I'll take it oh I see the power
we're gonna say Jesse Yeah well it's a
good thing I noticed that it's about to
cut out if I can maybe ease your
concerns maybe not
obviously everyone knows there's a bunch
of crap going on when it comes to voting
but that doesn't that doesn't change
your community that unless you live in
Philadelphia or New York or something
like that your community those are the
votes that matter who's who's on your
school board who's on who's your D.A
who's your sheriff who's on your city
council there's not some gigantic uh
election cheating scheme in your
community we have we here I live in
Texas May 6th we have elections are are
the Republicans going to actually show
up and participate now they're not sexy
it's not president it's not Trump but
scientists in the presidency they're
boring freaking city council candidates
and all that other we get out voted in
those and it's not cheating they show up
two three four to one while we sit at
home and are we gonna show up or not
okay they have an urban Advantage
because of population density it's
easier for them to expand their ground
game and harder for people in rural
areas maybe otherwise you come over I've
become overly obsessed with Federal
politics and I've become do you realize
all all the right has even if you
consider yourself there all the right
has because the right house says
horrible savior complex because we're
busy we have jobs families they want one
person to just win just when the
presidency and fix it fix it Trump uh
just fix it to Santas and I know one of
those guys is going to be able to fix
anything it starts locally it starts in
your community we start local protect
your community fortify it and then we
expand it from there eventually we get
to Washington DC Freedom's never going
to come from Washington DC let me ask
you about uh that Gathering you had
whether your neighbors came to you like
like let's get specific on that like so
so what happened they show up and
they're like hey Jesse what's up with
this beer thing uh well we were who
knows all the conversation that was
going on that all the the beer thing
this weekend it was it was immediate to
him it was not it was not well something
that came up after a while everybody
because everyone usually drives golf
carts around the neighborhood or just
walks to wherever we're going seeing
who's out and about lawn chairs and
stuff like that everyone as they walked
up was talking about they was the number
one subject on everyone's mine they were
all talking about it I'm getting rid of
it I'm done forever crap I'm embarrassed
I didn't bring mine because I didn't
want to get made fun of I'm never buying
it that's it right there it was it was I
didn't want to get made fun of oh yeah
that's the power of see this is what the
left uses they use shame but if the dude
Bros are concerned about being made fun
of they're not going to do it but that's
why I was saying like you can simplify
it for everybody and be like don't worry
guys Beer's on me and they go yeah and
then you show up with a different brand
do you guys think that that we need to
unify against a common enemy do you
think that we need that that's why I
wrote the anti-communist manifesto which
can be purchased at jessiekellybook.com
no no listen and all seriously in all
seriousness that's why that's why I talk
about anti-communism so much I the Right
must unify if we talk about Libertarians
and conservatives in a nationalists and
all these different parts of the right
and I'm not dismissing any of those
parts and the different points any of
them make I have I have my own desire is
there but what we're doing when we talk
when we spend all this time what should
the end result be should should tax tax
rates be here or there should what we're
actually doing is we're sitting inside
the courtyard of a castle and we're
we're we're coming at each other about
what color the drapes should be and how
tall the building should be while the
enemy hordes are coming through the
front gates to kill us all we stop the
left first or all these arguments the
right has about what should or shouldn't
be they're all meaningless none of it
means anything at all these people will
steal kill and destroy everything once
we stop them then we can have that
argument and anti-communism is all that
matters here's the important thing I
think needs to be said
these people have been engaged in this
for a lot longer than you oh yeah Pros
you look at you look at the the analogy
I was making about the battle map you
look at gamergate that institutional
power was behind that and we watched the
subversion of our institutions my
favorite is the Free Press an
organization I've known for a long time
called for the Banning of Alex Jones
so wait wait wait just a gosh darn
minute in 2011 they were like the free
press needs to stand and Independent
Media is important and then a few years
later they're like Alex Jones is evil
it's like aren't you guys the Free Press
why are you advocating for the removal
of a media well because it's fake news
I'm like what does the since when did
you take the position on what is allowed
to be news or not but here's my point
the right is now actively and angrily
pushing back in a way that's
unprecedented the way it's always been
viewed before is that the left is
pulling the entire country as hard as
possible leftward and the right was only
resisting a little bit
um or a better way to explain it is the
Republicans are Democrats driving the
speed limit now the chain snapped the
Democrats have driven off the edge and
Republicans are stopping and saying no
more we're not moving this is the point
where we've actually seen active
resistance to the woke uh takeover
after a long period of time that's why
I'm optimistic on this because you know
I see the the only way the left wins is
if
people on the right stop and say you
know what I agree with the left and then
join them because what we're facing
right now is their cities are crumbling
and Narco tyranny doesn't work what
they're trying to do is destabilize
police departments destabilize cities in
an effort to take things over de Blasio
said during lockdowns that uh something
the effect of buying up property as
prices collapse and then converting it
to public housing but but these these
policies only result in them losing
influence in power because despite what
they may hope with ESG and all that
stuff meritocracy still has a large grip
true capitalism still is a large grip if
you can't make money you can't get power
from it they can try manipulating the
Federal Reserve they can try and give
out loans and all that stuff but they
still need to be able to Garner
influence and for the first time
probably in Forever the right stuck a
stake in the ground and said we're not
moving now they're dealing with a
collapse in their own influence and
resistance at the same time I look at it
mathematically and say if every if I
were to step back from all of this and
just go into a tower and watch and I
started doing the math the math to me
looks like it will be a hard-fought
battle but the right will win either
through attrition or through
perseverance what can something the left
doesn't have what concerns me we're in
Austin right now I went around for a
walk earlier today and I saw like some
signs in yards like Beto O'Rourke trans
rights are humans rights and I'm like
you know what when I was in LA we would
have parties where I'd go to a party
there'd be a trans guy or a girl uh
there'd be someone that barely spoke
English to be a communist there'd be a
Conservative Christian like and we'd all
get along and we would all talk politics
and we would all get along but I go to
this website I keep James Lindsay
brought this up beautiful trouble.org
it's a training website on how to do
direct violent action creatively and
it's like a pop-up get in trouble it
says so like how do you combat or resist
active attempts to organize destruction
active attempts to organize this
instructions but sorry this is my point
you should pull this website they're
destroying their own cities why am I
going to cry about it because they're my
cities too well not any longer dude get
out of cities too
what's the website economic Heartland
beautifultrouble.orging that we should
you gotta shine a light on this crap
well I mean maybe it doesn't say
anything violent on the website it's
real flowery but
and keep training keep in mind Creative
Energy injection and your direct action
here's the time the problem it the
problem the real true heart of the
problem is not necessarily the street
animals the street animals are always an
issue don't get me wrong and they hurt
people and whatnot but the mob wasn't
powerful back when they were powerful
because they shot a bunch of people in
the head the mob was powerful back when
they were powerful because they owned
the positions of power they own the
judges and they own the cops and they
own the the they own the government
positions I disagree that's what the
gate well it's true that's what gave
them their true power that's why that's
why any organized crime in any area that
really takes hold the reason they can
keep out other organized crime when you
think they just go shoot them in it's
because he's just gonna have that like
the cartels in Mexico half the times
they use the cops to kill you the cops
will show right right arrest you take
you out and shoot you in the face the
problem we have in America is
they own the FBI they own the doj they
own the CIA the only NSA they all
they're from up on high from the
president on down oh wow you're a pro uh
you're a pro-life guy reading Bible
verses in an abortion clinic boom
abortion felony try to put him away
forever you're some uh I think it was a
transsexual guy today attacked the
Catholic church doj is recommending no
charges but but don't have the guys on
top and that's the issue and to it to a
certain degree I think it is but
confidence is the principle issue and
the reason why many judges won't uphold
the law is because they fear antifa now
you can say there's a component of this
and antifa will get away with crimes
therefore antifa is more confident in
committing crimes and getting away with
it but it all to me looks like one big
Mexican standoff
I see a bunch of people standing in a
crowd who don't like wokeness but will
not be the person to say anything
because they think everyone will then
turn to them the average person in my
opinion let's look at that business in
Portland kawava that's shut down I'm
willing to bet that these people work at
this Cafe in downtown Portland would put
flyers in the window saying black lives
matter and you know in this house we
believe science is real and go Biden
2020. even though they don't like the
ideas even though they despise the
ideology they would put those signs in
their window out of fear that if they
don't antifa will come and smash their
Windows they have confidence
that and it doesn't mean a good thing it
means they truly believe that if they
don't adhere their business will be
destroyed but this is my point their
business was already destroyed even even
their capitulation to the far left
extremists and their feigning of support
for them still resulted in their
destruction of their business that's why
I'm like look
confidence is everything if at any point
people no longer have confidence in law
enforcement law enforcement may as well
not exist you can see this in other
countries if you don't think a cop can
do anything to you you won't listen to
that cop in the United States we do fear
the police because we are confident if
we break the law we will get arrested
and we will go to jail and the book will
be thrown at us now we're starting to
see in these big cities that ain't true
so crime is running rampant and people
are doing whatever they want which is
resulting in economic collapse the seats
of power may be beneficial but only so
far as human beings are actually working
on a system
that can maintain itself right let's
let's slow down all back up
when we talk about third fourth and
fifth generational Warfare the question
is
if you could take over a country without
firing a single bullet
would you do it right if you want to
take over country and there was a means
but by which you could do it without
firing a single bullet or engaging in
any violent action would you do it well
the answer is of course because violence
is expensive and resource heavy if there
was a cheaper and easier way to do
anything you'd do it so that's why we
see information Warfare
these people need power they want power
in order to have power people have to do
things that benefit them and Empower
them
so if they're a judge if they're in
charge of law enforcement in a city with
no people
they have nothing
those seats of Power are completely
meaningless if confidence in those
cities has shattered to simplify it even
a great to a greater degree if there are
a hundred people and one person becomes
the chief of police
so long as those people keep working and
paying taxes and they believe that chief
of police has power that chief police
can get those people to do whatever he
wants he can then Implement changes he
can put whatever flag he wants and those
people fear him but if it comes to a
point where no matter what happens these
people are failing and their businesses
are destroyed they're just going to say
the system doesn't exist and I'll give
you I'll give you another example of
where I think this is going and why I
think this the founding fathers talked
about the right of the presumption of
innocence
the rooted in the story of Sodom and
Gomorrah
the idea that it is better that 10
guilty persons Escape than one innocent
person suffer is not just about
protecting individuality it was about
protecting the system itself
if you have a society where everyone
believes that no matter what they do
whether they're good or bad they will be
punished one there's no incentive to be
good at all look I'm gonna go work my
job and be honest but those guys are
destroying everything they're stealing
everything and they're not getting
arrested what's the point of being good
I might as well join them but
if the system says if you were a good
person we will do everything in our
power to make sure the weight of
government is never pressed against you
you will have the presumption of
innocence then the the pressure is
created that says to a person be the
innocent one don't be the criminal and
the system will make sure you are safe
so now that they're creating cities and
institutions that punish people no
matter what they do they're actually
gutting and destroying their own their
own structures their own institutions
their own power base and that's why I
was saying so long as these cities and
places like Florida and Texas exist that
are turning redder or West Virginia
they can do whatever they want they're
knocking the legs out from their own
structures and we are building up hours
stronger and better than ever so I say
who cares let them do it I think of that
though San Francisco I see the homeless
is I keep hearing about how horrible it
is and I think part of me has this like
malicious grin on the inside where I'm
like good they deserved it then the
other part of me is like they do am I a
horrible human for feeling that way no
they do what's wrong with me that I
would would enjoy that or you know Annie
Glee you're supposed to you're actually
let me explain by you thinking that what
you just said right now that makes you a
bad person you know why because these
people voted for this stuff and I have a
smile on my face saying I'm so happy for
you that you got what you asked for you
should be very very happy thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time